the prequels were underrated
I mean by not by the not by the people
that love that so we made them for in
fact yeah underrated at the time at the
time yeah just just needed a little bit
of time you know to sort of ferment in
our popular culture yeah yeah but I
think they were appreciated at the time
by the by the generation we made them
for if you like it's just that that took
there was no social media then there was
no that we didn't hear their voice as
much as
as you would do nowadays you know with a
film that coming out now you there's no
question what people think about it
because you can see it on social media
and the the audience's voice is much
louder now if you like
um and at the time basically the
reaction was driven by the critics who
decided they weren't as good as the
original film or or and George always
had a
you know he always had a very strong
idea to make them diff to make them
different kinds of movies he wasn't he
didn't set out to remake what he'd done
in the 70s